[Music]
well hello and welcome everyone let's
get things started for day two of next
let's start by a quick stop pole uh
raise your hand if you ever had to build
an ETL pipeline which was largely
copying data so that you can enable a
business use
case quite a few
keep your hands up if you felt that
after creating that pipeline you
increased the complexity of managing
that data or security and
governance well quite a few so that's
really the Crux of the session today we
will really be talking about how how you
can actually build a architecture that's
predicated on a single copy lake house
one that allows you to make sense of all
of your data with all analytics and AI
engines and do so in a secure governed
and performant manner
my name is gorov Sak I'm a group product
manager here at Google Cloud focused on
lak house Ai and analytics and I have
the pleasure of joining me today is
Rohit danan who is uh Chief technology
officer for acutance Tech platform who
will be sharing insights and learnings
from their lake house
Journey so first of all I do want to
start off by saying that this is a super
exciting time we are at the dawn of
generative Ai and there are lots of
reasons that you might have heard why
people are excited about this but I want
to point out two specific things that
are very relevant to the lake house
topic well first of all if you look at a
typical Enterprise today we are only
scratching the surface in terms of the
percentage of data that's really
recurring into value and a large part
reason of that today is if you look at
businesses today they generate a lot of
data every time a support interaction
happens every time uh a customer leaves
a feedback on an online platform or
creates a video that's a lot of
unstructured or multimodal data thatting
created the problem was that the tools
to unlock that was very expensive well
now generative AI is going to has the
promise to solve that particular problem
and really make sense of all your data
second the assistive technologies will
help every data practitioner each one of
us to do more and this is why it's super
excited that it needs to be kind of
grounded in the context of your
Enterprise data well and while a lot of
focus has been on AI models the heart of
AI is data and this is why many you have
been already thinking about these use
case or trying out these use cases today
have been
asking how do I connect data to use
cases easily and to do so in a secure
manner governed Manner and to be able to
do it without writing a lot of custom
infrastructure let's talk about how a
gcp lake house helps you achieve these
things so the biggest problem when it
comes to connecting data to use cases is
really the siloed nature of the data
Lake the data warehouse and the AI stack
each layer in the stack has its own way
to access data and its own way to manage
metadata well what this really means is
if you are going to start up an AI
project or a AI use case and if that
data is present in a warehouse you will
now right to have ETL job to pull the
data out and as pointed out through a
stop Pole that really becomes
challenging well that complexity only
increases if that data is in different
formats or in different clouds besides
the security and governance challenges
all of these the physics of moving the
data really comes in the way and while
this is extremely painful for us data
Engineers ultimately this slows down
value generation and and we are today
here to look at how we can really help
this kind of use cases
now last year to address some of these
problems at at this very conference we
announced Big Lake big lake is a storage
engine that unifies your data Lake
warehouse and AI workloads it does so by
providing a single fabric of data over
which multiple engines can interact with
and do so in a secure and govern manner
it abstracts and decouples some of the
common shared infrastructure from query
engines such as metadata and security
and abstracts into a runtime on its own
this is what allows query engines to
interface with all the data underneath
spanning across formats and Cloud
boundaries and to be able to access that
data with built-in fine grain access
control and also with price
performance ever since the beginning of
this year we have seen a lot of growth
with many of you building these lake
houses in fact processing over big lake
has really increased by 27x beginning of
this year and the first question that
many of you are asking is what table
formats does pig L support table formats
have really taken off in the last three
years because of the promise of
providing Rich data management
capabilities over open format data
Apache Iceberg Delta or hoodie are
popular names we have specifically seen
a lot of interest in Apachi Iceberg and
this is why I'm excited to share that
the support for apachi iceberg is now
generally available in Big Lake you can
create or modify an iceberg table from
open source engine such as spark and
that table can automatically become
available for your big query users to go
query and consume this is made possible
through a shared meta store architecture
big lck meta store is a shared metastore
between open source engines and big
query making it easy for you to uh
access your open source tables directly
in bigquery and quer it when it comes to
querying big query natively understands
Iceberg metadata and and this is what
makes it really easy for big query to
not only deliver a performant query
experience but to deliver it with full
fine R Access Control model it Big L
enforces find access control over your
Iceberg data and enforces it when you're
aquaring from Big query as well as from
open source engines when you're going
through the big lake interface this
really makes sure that not only running
open source Iceberg but you are actually
running in a secure Manner and you are
running in a performant manner and you
are integrating all of the data which
was already present in bigquery or in
other
places while Iceberg has dramatically
accelerated the adoption of open lake
houses on Google Cloud some of you have
already been using Delta or hoodie for
your workloads for specific use cases
and this is why I'm also really excited
to announce today that Delta and Hoodie
is Now supported through big query
manifest you can now create a big L
table by pointing to manifest generated
from apachi hoodi or from from Delta and
that table can now be queried from Big
query the Manifest support now supports
partitioning as well which means we scan
less data every time you're running
queries against these open
formats lastly the same security model
that we spoke about of iceberg in
context of find and access control all
of those features also work on Delta as
well as on hoodie which means you can
either use big query or open source
engines to query these tables with row
column access control or through Dynamic
data
masking besides the support for table
format many of you also ask about query
performance it's really one of the chief
characteristics when choosing a
particular technology stack to run on
and performance has been an important
area of focus for us this is why what we
have been doing is really expanding the
underlying infrastructure that we've
already used for big query it's called
Big metadata that really represents Rich
metadata data profile I all extended to
open formats so that we can capture Rich
Park status and metadata and use that
effectively for query planning all of
this a meant that on The tpcs Benchmark
we are now 4X faster than we were before
on big query external tables and this
increased performance by the virtue of
leveraging metadata also means that we
have to scan less data reducing the cost
of running these queries and posing a
75% reduction when compared to bigquery
external tables so if you are running
bigquery external tables today it's
really a no-brainer to upgrade those to
bigli tables and get better performance
lower cost and fin an access control for
your
workloads put put together these tools
will really help you connect more of
your data and more of your formats and
across clouds to more use cases and
really help Advance the development of
analytics and
AI now now another big area that keeps
coming up all the time is that many of
you have said that we really want to
pursue an open format strategy and
reasons range from long-term vend
neutrality or being compatible or
interoperable with multicloud or hybrid
architectures a single format can make
that easy but management of data is
painful you have to ride a lot of these
background jobs to constantly optimize
file sizes garbage collection
or be able to do features that will
optimize your overall query performance
and impact the TCO of your overall
workload this is why and this particular
problem also gets even more complex when
you are doing use cases like high
throughput streaming change data capture
which results into the dreaded small
file problem that really ends up
impacting query performance and had
requires a lot more infrastructure
maintenance and management to just keep
the workload really running in a
performing man
specifically when there are use cases
like gdpr which often require you to
perform deletion operations at a
granular level those becomes really
expensive because the open formats are
really modifying uh multiple files and
the toity could be a batch of files so
uh these are some of the challenges that
many have been asking and they are
solvable but they require a lot of work
that creates U infrastructure this is
I'm super thrilled to announce something
special that we've been working on over
the course of last year it's called Big
Lake manage tables that provides a fully
managed lake house experience for your
open format data it provides DML and
transactions on your parket workloads
for your data deciding in your cloud
storage buckets it provides a fully
managed lout experience with automatic
background storage optimizations such as
file compaction and garbage collection
to help you make sure that you are
running Optimal Performance and cost
and it provides an interface to do
extremely high throughput streaming
ingestion that scales to tens of
gigabytes for the most demanding
workloads Paving the way for CDC and
other Advanced analytics use cases that
you can now run on open format
data the key underlying principle for us
has been openness where data stays in
your buckets and it it's managed in open
formats all of this is enabled in a
fully open architecture by bu building
in full compatibility with Iceberg Big
Lake manage tables provide Iceberg
metadata so that your open source
engines can query it just like if they
were query ice spook
tables Big Lake manage tables really
brings the best of Google manage storage
management infrastructure that has
already been tested at massive scale
with big query and innovates on it to
make it optimized and work on your open
format data we are very excited about
this there are three key ways in which
you can use biglick manage tables let me
start by calling this out first one you
can use bigquery to perform DML
ingestion into your tables just like you
would do on a big query native table and
then big query will uh Big Lake will
actually uh perform all of these
underlying data management operations
such as file compaction autoc clustering
clustering of data automatic
reclustering as well as garbage ction to
make sure that you don't have to ride
these infrastructure task and you still
get a very performant experience at the
right price
point if you are building streaming
pipelines that's the second use case
where you can now use the bigquery right
API to actually write data to these
tables using connectors from popular
open source engines like spark or just
build your own client Library based
connectors to write it from your own
custom engines and this really scales to
several gigabits per second
part of the reason why this becomes
possible is that historically when you
are building High throughput steaming
pipelines you are constrained by the
right throughput from object stores or
the transactions on the open
formats Big Lake manage tables take an
approach where inje is First ridden into
a right optimized storage that is
massively paralyzed and then it's
converted into parquet into colum ner
this really allows inje to really scale
up to extremely high limits for the most
demanding workloads but yet provide you
rate zero rate Stillness your queries
actually merge the data between par as
well as the right optimize store to make
sure there is no latency when you're
quering the
results and then files uh the small
files are automatically uh compacted in
in optimal manner to ensure the best
performance uh and third is that you can
now also use open source engines to
query these tables via the iceb
snapshots and the big link zero trust
security model of find an access control
also applies in these use cases so these
are just some of the ways we are already
seeing customers build capabilities
around this and with that let me invite
Rohit from rakuen to share a little bit
more about their Journey on lak house
and key learnings from it thank you GV
and thank you for sharing uh sharing
with us the exciting features of uh of
Big Lake uh so my name is Rohit Divan I
am the CTO of the platforms group at uh
at rocken and so while got talked about
all the features of Big Lake I wanted to
get more into kind of our motivations
around moving towards the lake house
architecture and some of the
considerations we had in uh in choosing
big
lake so rockan is a pretty fascinating
company we were actually founded back in
1997 as the first uh e-commerce
Marketplace in Japan and starting in the
early 2000s we started diversify into
credit card travel um other fintech
businesses and kind of fast forward to
today uh we're a conglomerate of uh more
than 70 businesses that connect together
in a ecosystem through a common
membership and a common Rewards program
known as uh known as super
points
um if you're in Japan you pretty much
can't miss us I mean almost 3% of Japan
GDP goes through Rakuten in some way so
we had almost I think last year about 34
trillion Japanese yen in uh in in
transaction volume and so as you can
Imaginee we have pretty much very
incredible breadth and depth of uh
data so we have a I mean you can see our
mission statement up there I imagine
many of you in your data platform
organizations have something uh
something similar um but this going to
simple Mission hides a lot of complexity
behind it so one is just a sheer number
of users we have uh more than 2,000 data
analysts hundreds of data Engineers
hundreds of data scientists and also as
a global ecosystem company um we have
dozens of people who are working on
governance audit security making sure
we're compliant with gdpr CCPA and the
variety of kind of data protection
regimes around the world many
Acquisitions also means that we're deao
multicloud so we're using all the major
hyper hypers scalers and uh and we're
Global as well so at our level of
complexity I think one of the key
considerations is that any core data
data platform process needs to be
automated was any manual step simply
would not would not scale at at our at
our
level so starting in about 2000 we we
started on our I'd say data platform
modernization journey and back then we
were actually a purely uh kind of on
premise system uh but as a very
datadriven
organization um the pressure on that
system was growing very very rapidly I
think at some point point we're looking
at 1 or 2% growth per week which
compounded is is absolutely massive so
in order to achieve kind of more
elasticity and scale we decided to move
towards a hybrid data platform and so as
of last year so this is October of last
year uh we are now fully hybrid so we
have our data both on premise as well as
on gcp now of course this comes with its
uh own set of challenges we move from
just having say object storage and
Hadoop on Prem to now also having data
replicas in GCS and also copying that
over into into big query storage as well
so from a governance perspective this is
increasing our uh our our load because
we need to make sure that permissions
are aligned across all these different
uh all these different systems um at the
same time from a data engineering or
scientist perspective there's a long
time to get value from that data so once
data was produced we we need to run
pretty heavy ETL jobs now to copy it
into say big query where the bulk of our
users were then going to consume it so
they might be like several hours or or
more of delay to get that uh time to
value and additionally we had to as we
made copies through these uh
replicas uh we needed to be able to
monitor quality to make sure that the
copies are available and consistent
across each replica which is much more
complicated than it sounds so this was
kind of real motivation to say we should
consider a lake house
architecture so fast forward to today
and so we were one of the early launch
Partners uh for big lake and we've been
able to reduce our number of data
replicas in half so on Prem we uh we
moving to just object storage and on on
gcp uh we're able to keep all our data
within GCS and for the most part not
have to copy that into into BQ storage
so this is of course now reducing the
time to data um it also simplifies our
our governance and access because our
governance teams can set uh set policies
um right essentially in one place and
have them apply to our data whether it
be on Prem whether it be on gcp in AWS
or Azure um in addition kind of all all
consumption is is going can go through
big lake as well so there are big lake
connectors for all the popular query
interfaces at least the ones that we use
um like BQ and uh and
trino um I should mention we also have
very significant cross use of data and
that makes our governance even more
complicated um but definitely moving to
Big Lake has uh has helped us to
simplify that uh
significantly so as we were going uh
making this journey to Lakehouse there
were these were I'd say the five kind of
primary considerations we had so one was
performance so we were definitely
concerned that moving to um not having
data and big query storage would lead to
a a significant reduction in performance
um however in our testing uh we found
that if metadata caching is turned on
the performance nearly approached I'd
say like 98 99% approached the native
performance um if that data were in were
in BQ
storage um we wanted to have fewer
copies of data and definitely that's
something we were able to achieve with
big lake as well and so getting much
faster and realtime insights we're able
to set policies in in in one place so
definitely it's our ciso is having fewer
sleepless nights as uh as we are as
well Iceberg support is something that
was important to us I think as a company
we believe that's uh that's going to be
the standard uh standard format going
forward and so in a future phase uh
probably later this year we'll also be
adding taking advantage of uh this the
iceberg support um that's part of the
big lake Big Lake
ecosystem so net net I think big lake um
meets all these considerations and has
helped us to kind of achieve the next
step in our lake house journey I
definitely wish you all the best uh in
your next step I mean so many of you
showed up for an 8 a.m. session which
tells me a lot of you are thinking about
this topic as uh as well um I won't be
present during the Q&A but I will hang
around uh for some minutes after the
after the session uh to answer any
questions you might have thank you so
much for your
[Applause]
time let me pass back to
garv
partnership uh well Rohit mentioned a
lot about how getting to a lak house
simplified their old data architecture
and really enabled uh many personas to
come together and consume that single
copy of data uh now as many of you been
talking about uh lak houses uh one of
the big challenges that we've been
already hearing a lot is that how do we
solve the data problem of the AI let me
explain what I mean by that there's a
lot of value that many of our customers
are exploring in the foundation models
but to really make it relevant and
really work for their Enterprise use
cases it needs to be grounded in their
data it not only needs to be grounded in
their data uh but it needs to happen in
a manner that's secure govern private
and do all of that in a manner that does
not really blow up price performance so
to how do you really do AI in a scalable
manner by bringing your own data with
security and governance that's already
building that you've already curated and
this is where the big lake house
opportunity is to really simplify those
challenges for you
so uh we mentioned that the analytics
and AI lake house has for long been
siloed where analytics has largely
focused on the structured data but then
AI especially generative AI which is now
unlocking all this value from
unstructured data had almost like a
separate path to get to the public Cloud
object stores where this data is rely
stored so the challenge we asked to the
team back is how do we help customers
get access to their data using the tools
that they are already amiliar with using
the governance Frameworks that they are
already using and this is why I'm really
excited to announce the general
availability of object tables object
tables are a layer on top of public
Cloud object stores they represent
metadata of underlying files that are
stored in public loud buckets and they
are special kind of table because they
have the ability to actually retrieve
the underlying object and serve it to
the processing engine to run AI
computation on top of it these object
tables are also really simplified to
develop pipelines when you add new
objects to the pipelines let's say new
images got added to a bucket the table
automatically updates and really
simplifies end2end development of AI
pipelines and finally object tables
enforce big lakes fine security model
which means if you are securing a
specific Row in the object table you are
actually securing the underlying image
and the retrieval of that image that can
happen to the signed
URL these capabilities make it really
easy to build these use cases let me
give you some examples of use cases
today that we are seeing well first up a
lot of companies today as they are
building their own versions of
Enterprise llms or fine-tuning
Foundation models to build their own
versions are first needing to do
pre-training this is where we call about
how do you actually take the data that
you have collected from various sources
in Object Store like GCS but still be
able to uh transform it parse it
or be able to filter out for things like
opts outs or training license rights
which is largely stored in structure
tables or it's extracted from this
data through big query object tables you
can now join object tables with rest of
your other big query tables where you
can write simple expressive SQL
statements that help you curate your
training carpus for this fine training
to happen this makes it really really
simple that otherwise would take a lot
of coding to
develop the other thing that we are
already seeing is once you actually get
to a model how do you know that it's
really safe for your use cases how do
you know it's really high quality and
giving good responses this is where you
can create object tables and call that
object call that model uh directly using
big query whether it's hosted in verx or
whether it's hosted in managed by you on
your own custom infrastructure through
simple lines a few lines of SQL we are
already seeing examples where Customs
are creating this object table over
images and then use it bigquery SQL to
call Vision API to figure out safety
elements of the image and then be able
to take action on it one of the actions
is really how do you actually secure
specific Pi objects if you detect
specific metadata and you can then cut
off that access to specific groups or
user admin personas to be able to make
sure that the AI development that you
are doing is consistent with the
governance that policies that you have
described for your own
organization we're now taking these
capabilities one step further where if
you think about the documents use cases
a lot of data whether it's PDF files or
text files resides in object stores well
now you can use document AI workbench
and with just a few clicks you can train
a custom llm extractor to extract
specific things asked from the document
you can ask a question um to really
figure out what specific fields and
schema you want to Define for your
extraction and that's created that
really generates a API endpoint that
gets deployed well that API can now be
called using big query remote models you
can simply register that remote model in
big query with SQL and write SQL on
object tables on PDF files to be able to
invoke that API and then be able to
extract text from the documents find GRE
access control like I said is already
baked into the framework so you can
really control if you want to secure
access to specific documents that
contain sensitive information or PR
information well you can then build
document analytics in bigquery by
combining with rest of your structured
data or you can also do other many
interesting things with it we are seeing
opportunities to take that extracted
text in big query and with the latest
capabilities that we announced yesterday
on embedding generation you can now
generate embeddings on those text
columns that embedding an index can then
be sync to the vortex matching engine
where you can actually leverage vectors
search to implement your Enterprise llm
chatbots that is grounded in your data
to implement techniques like retrieval
augmented generation and all of these
capabilities make it really really
simple with few lines of SQL to bring
your data to make custom tuned LM
applications to do and to do it by
preserving security and privacy in a
govern
manner so I'm really excited with all
the capabilities that we shared with you
today and the experience from Rohit and
his team to help kind of build these
lake houses and we can't wait to see how
you'll actually build in your own
[Music]
Journey